I know you can't reveal too much but I'm
very curious you got to be part of this
Mandalorian show on Disney Plus are you
allowed to say anything or is it
completely NDA well you know they
haven't reached out to me in a while
I've really an intense love and respect
for Jon Favreau what can I say I got a
great costume
we got great set pieces you know I'm not
giving anything away because this guy is
an artist truly an artist working with
your clues Lucas on this particular
piece Mandalorian and making it a piece
that we can really relate to now in our
world that we're in besides the fact
that there's so many Star Wars fans and
freaks out there that really don't get
enough of this finally we have a piece
first time ever shot outside of a London
studio Jon Favreau's brilliant
technically this show is as a new
technology never really refined as much
as it is right now
we're in a place called the volume where
we do most of our acting we're set
pieces are bought in or they can control
the physical atmosphere of what is
projected on the walls and control how
gravity is you get a feeling that
gravity is being played with this is a
show that's gonna be really fantastic I
won't tell you a new storyline but I
tell you really wonderful to be able to
work with people in this vein because I
haven't done a lot you know John and I
heed the revolution we did Jungle Book
together
we did a commercial for destiny that led
to Jungle Book from our conversation and
destiny were rendered Kipling reading
that wonderful poem Mowgli The Jungle
Book story and Johnson would be great if
that was redone one day and I said man
that would be really fantastic a year
later he's calling me to do that so when
you have great minds who are just
creative thinking about how they can do
things that update do things that bring
new life into other stories that we've
seen before in a very new and different
way I'm always honored so when he called
me in and I said hey how many people
have done this how many people that I
know I the first guy I call the Sam
Jackson
and guess what I'm holding in my hand
you know to be it's you get excited and
I you know that just gets me going
completely they're actually doing a
panel at Star Wars Celebration tomorrow
where I think they're gonna show the
first trailer and all that stuff so it's
more stuff will get released tomorrow
then what and then I'll be like why ask
you about this well you know I'm glad
I'm I I'm not creating these spoilers at
all because I again I do respect also
had a driver yesterday right you brought
me over here and he said yeah I Drive
Vince Gilligan blah blah blah blah blah
I don't want to know anything first
thing he said to me I don't want to know
anything I said wow that's the first
time that's ever happened that's really
pretty fantastic I don't really want to
know even I'm actually a fan I want to
hear about what's cool about it but I
want it ruined I don't want the
experience ruined well you know what's
cool about mandalorian is that jon
favreau you know you figure a guy who
wrote it
figure it out with George Lucas would
direct every episode that would be all
ego right he has amassed some incredible
directors I'm a little of different
parts of the planet to give their take
on an episode I find that to be so
phenomenal because then we have new and
fresh ideas every single episode coming
into this particular show that reflect
the fans because directors are also fans
they're from Australia from England from
London from wherever you are
it reflects their take of their people
on how they saw the original and how
they're going to do it as well so you
get new fresh energy into a piece that
is already energetic because of all the
stuff that's going on the screen because
all the technicality that they've worked
out this is gonna be a fabulous show you
watch go tomorrow